>> Phoebe Connelly: We're going
to leave quite a bit of time
after the presentation
for questions.
So, about 15 minutes.
There's microphones
in the aisles
if you guys want to queue up.
And, I have been asked to
remind you that if you come
up to the microphone, you'll
be included in the videotape
of the event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
So, you'll be preserved
for all time
with your brilliant questions.
It's my absolute pleasure
to introduce my guest,
Sandhya Menon, author
of the two brilliant
and successful YA novels,
When Dimple Met Rishi,
and From Twinkle, With Love.
Menon is an active
Twitter account,
where she reminds her readers
that her name rhymes with
"Stunned-ya Melon," which
I think is the most clever
pronunciation guide I've seen.
When Dimple Met Rishi was a
New York Times best seller.
And, From Twinkle, With
Love published in May.
So, I mentioned the
Q and A. But,
also Menon will be
signing books.
So, if you have your copies,
and you want to get them signed,
she will be signing books at
11:30 here at the festival.
So, Sandhya, I want to
start by thanking you
for the absolutely lovely
weekend, which I spent
in the company of
Dimple and Twinkle.
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, thank you.
>> Phoebe Connelly: I
found both characters to be
so honest, and warm, and true.
And, I found reading these books
to be a really joyful
experience.
Was writing them a
joyful experience?
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
I like to say that,
especially now, I really look
at writing as my escape.
And so, nothing gives me
more pleasure than going
into an office and getting to
spend hours with characters
who I know are going
to be OK in the end.
And, who makes lots of
corny jokes along the way,
and I get to write kissing
scenes, and get paid for them.
I mean-- I'm so lucky.
So, absolutely, yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
These are books
that are absolutely
about representation.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: And, how did
you find your way into the voice
of your young characters?
>> Sandhya Menon: It was
definitely trial and error.
I was actually self-publishing
before my publisher, you know,
found me and all that stuff,
so I was writing for adults,
and then the opportunity to
write young adult fiction came,
and I was absolutely having a
moment, like, can I do this?
I've never down this before.
And, you know, I
haven't been a teenager
for quite a long time now.
So, I had to go back to, you
know, what was high school like,
which for me was extremely
painful and awkward.
And, I didn't know what was
happening half the time,
because I had moved to
the U.S. when I was 15,
right in the middle
of high school.
But, there was such great
fodder to mine there,
because of those experiences.
And, although my
characters are all American.
They're, you know,
American-born, I think some
of those high school
experiences are very universal.
And, they are still burned
fresh in my mind to this day.
So, I think I'll have lots
of material for a while.
And then, plus, in my
other job, I'm a therapist,
and I work with a lot of
adolescents, so, you know,
I absolutely don't write
about my clients, of course.
But, you know, it
helps me stay current
with what's important
to adolescents now.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: For both of
these characters, their passion,
or I think, when they're
a little bit older,
I hope that their
profession is so core
to how they see themselves
in the world.
Why did you do that with
both of these characters?
>> Sandhya Menon: I think
one of my favorite things
in the world is passionate
people.
And, I remember when I was
in high school, I don't know
if people have this perception
that adolescents don't
really know what they want,
or you know, they're
wishy washy,
but that wasn't my experience.
Every friend I had, and
almost every person I knew
in high school, was
absolutely passionate
about what they wanted to do.
Ad, even the adolescents
I see now,
everybody has this kernel
inside of them, and sometimes
that kernel is stomped out,
or, you know, people are told
that it's not important,
and don't pursue that,
and that's not a
worthwhile career.
But, it's still there.
And, that to me is, kind of,
what makes adolescents shine
so brightly, is that it's
just this entire world
of possibility.
And, you could go
anywhere and be anything.
And, that's so incredible to me.
>> Phoebe Connelly: How did you
go about getting the details
of their passions,
coding or film making,
how did you get those
details right?
>> Sandhya Menon:
So, with coding,
it was a lot more
challenging, because contrary
to what some readers think,
I am not a technical
kind of person at all.
So, I had to reach out to a lot
of different people
in the field.
My husband is actually
in cybersecurity,
and he had a lot of contacts.
I reached out to other female
friends who were in STEM
and asked, hey, this is
what I'm trying to say.
How do you say it in
technical language?
You know, that kind of thing.
And then, also what would a
coder, kind of, think about?
And, how does she think?
The way she thinks is very
different from how I think,
because I'm much more
creative and a writer,
versus, you know, a coder.
And then, as far as-- there's,
in Dimple, there's a lot of talk
about females in--
female coders.
And, that was my research.
I just went online and read a
ton of articles about, you know,
the challenges that
women in STEM face.
So, I have done-- I
have some psychological
research background.
And so, while that's
not coding, research,
kind of, has the same issues.
And so, I was able to draw
on my own experiences
for that as well.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes,
there's a great scene
where she sits down
with her idol.
She doesn't win the contest,
but she gets the chance
to sit down with here.
And, they have a really
frank conversation
about the challenges women
face in the workplace.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
Yes. And, I think that's
what was so important for me,
was that there has to
be a female mentor.
I am tired of, you know,
this idea that there are no
female mentors, because this is
such a male-dominated field.
They're actually there,
they just don't get the
spotlight a whole lot.
And so, I really wanted
to show Dimple connecting
with this woman who
had gone before her,
and done the things
that she wants to do.
>> Phoebe Connelly: So,
let's switch to Twinkle.
She wants to be a film maker.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: And, she's
writing all these letters
to female film makers.
And, I kind of [inaudible]
confirmed with you beforehand,
there's 17 different film
makers that she writes to.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Where did you come
up with this list of
women film makers?
>> Sandhya Menon: So, I was--
as I was researching this book,
I saw this statistic
that said in 2016,
which was only 2 years ago,
out of the top 250 movies made,
only 7% were directed by women.
And, that doesn't even
count, you know, ethnicity,
or LGBTQ community status,
or anything like that.
So, I started thinking,
well, how many movies--
because I love movies,
and I was like,
how many movies have I watched
that have had women
film directors?
And, I couldn't think
of that many.
So, I went on this quest to
watch movies directed by women
so that I could write this book,
and know what I was
talking about.
And, in the process, I also
bought a bunch of books
where female directors talk
about their experiences,
and things like that, which
was really amazing to, kind of,
see firsthand, what they, you
know, what they were dealing
with as they went through it.
And, so that's kind
of my research,
was actually watching
the movies.
Of course, you know, my husband
would come in and I'd have,
like, popcorn all over me,
and I'd be watching Netflix.
I'm like, go away, I'm working.
Yes, it's, like,
the best job ever.
[laughs]
>> Phoebe Connelly: How
do you like your popcorn?
>> Sandhya Menon:
How do I like it?
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
>> Sandhya Menon: I
like caramel popcorn,
so I'm all about the sweetness.
>> Phoebe Connelly: OK.
Did you have a favorite that you
revisited, or that you watched
for the first time when you
were doing the research?
>> Sandhya Menon: I actually
happen to love Ava DuVernay,
and I watched a lot
of her documentaries.
Like, I'd watched Selma already.
And then, I went back and I
watched Middle of Nowhere,
and some of her other ones.
And so, that was, kind of,
really, like, life-changing
for me, because Ava
DuVernay's story is just very
inspirational, and Twinkle has
a Ava DuVernay poster because,
you know, that was borne
from my absolute devotion.
So.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Did you see
A Wrinkle in Time in theaters?
>> Sandhya Menon: I did!
Yes. And, I loved that.
It was incredible.
I loved that.
>> Phoebe Connelly: I feel
like there's something
really incredible
about the way she
took this classic--
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: -- novel
that so many of us had read,
and really turned
it into what felt
like a totally new story to me.
>> Sandhya Menon: I know.
Exactly. And, I feel
like it's about time
that we saw different people
in the main characters'
roles, you know?
Like, I don't think any
of us, when we read it,
when we were kids envisioned
Meg as ever being black,
because she wasn't in the book.
But, in the movie she is,
and it absolutely works.
I love that.
I love being shown new
worlds and new people, in,
you know, old, kind of, roles.
Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Was there
a logic to how you paired
up which film maker she
wrote to with the contents
of the letter she wrote to them?
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
So, this is kind of a
behind the scenes look.
When I first wrote Twinkle,
I sold it before Dimple
had even come out.
And so, at that point, I
hadn't really thought--
and, my publisher hadn't really
thought of a brand for me,
or what kind of books I
was going to be writing
for the rest of my career.
So, I had written this book
as a very dark literary novel.
And so-- I know.
What was I thinking?
So, when Dimple came out, and it
did well, my publisher was like,
yes, you know-- they just
pushed the manuscript back
across the desk and said
this isn't really going
to work anymore.
So, if any of you are writers,
you'll know that there's no way
to shoehorn an old
idea into a new voice.
So, I basically had
to delete 80,000 words
of fiction, and re-write it.
It's OK, I'm over it now.
So, yes, so originally
it was very--
you know, with the
literary novel,
it was very closely
tied together.
There was-- she would very
carefully explain what the film
maker's film had
been about and tie it
to what she was going through.
However, as the book
got lighter in tone,
a lot of that had to go.
So, sometimes you'll still see
glimmers of that on the page,
but I didn't quite delve as
deeply into it this time.
Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
How do you watch films?
Do you like theaters?
Do you watch like
watching alone?
Do you watch them in groups?
>> Sandhya Menon: I
love watching alone,
because I get very
easily annoyed by people
who talk during the movie.
And, I'm like, I'm
trying to watch!
So, even my family,
I'm like, shh!
Stop munching your
popcorn so loudly.
A moment is happening, so.
I tend to watch alone,
by myself,
especially documentaries,
because not a lot
of people enjoy documentaries,
at least not
in my family, or in my life.
And so, I tend to-- it's
like a very spiritual
experience for me.
I have to sit down, like
me and the film maker.
You know? How weird
does that sound?
>> Phoebe Connelly: Why
do you like documentaries?
>> Sandhya Menon: I feel
like there's a truthfulness
and a realness to
them that you--
I don't want to say you
don't get in other films,
but it's just on a
different level for me.
And, I feel like I learn so
much about different things
that I would never
have considered
if I hadn't watched that film.
So, to me, that's sort
of like indie movies too,
because they just--
they're different,
and they make you think.
And, they present
different problems to you
than you're usually faced with.
So.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Do you have
a favorite documentary that you,
sort of, press on people and
say you have to watch this?
>> Sandhya Menon: No.
I knew you were going
to ask me that,
and I should have
researched this.
Any of Ava DuVernay's, but--
well, those are, kind of--
they're based on her experience,
they're not really
documentaries.
But, there's one about--
maybe you know this one.
But it's about clothing waste.
And, it's really powerful,
and it was recommended to me
by a college professor,
like, couple years ago.
I think it's still on Netflix.
But, it's amazing how much
clothing waste happens
in our country, and ends
up in the landfills.
Anyway, I'm not going to bore
you now about clothing waste,
but if you're interested,
I think it is on Netflix.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Alright, we'll look it up,
and we can tweet about it later,
and share it out with everyone.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
That's true.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Something to look forward to.
So, one of the ways that
I, just, found myself
in these books is
the way you write
about mothers and daughters.
You've said in previous
interviews that Dadi,
who is Twinkle's grandmother,
was one of your favorite
characters to write.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Talk
about that a little bit.
Why was she your favorite?
>> Sandhya Menon: I-- so,
in From Twinkle, With Love,
Twinkle has a very different
relationship with her parents
than Dimple does in When
Dimple Met Rishi, so-- sorry.
Twinkle's parents are very
disengaged from her life.
And, while that happens a lot,
I wanted her to have somebody
who was unconditionally
supportive of her, and believed
in her, even in those times that
she didn't believe in herself.
And, Dadi was absolutely
that person.
But, also Dadi kind of,
marches to her own tune.
And, she is very kooky, and very
eccentric, and kind of strange.
But, she and Twinkle
have this incredible bond
that nothing can break.
And, I really love the
idea of showing this mentor
for Twinkle who's
always in her corner,
even when Twinkle doesn't really
know who she is in certain parts
of the book, and she's
trying to figure it out.
But, Dadi's always,
like, this constant.
So.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
Twinkle's mother suffers
from depression in the book.
How did you land upon writing
about depression in one
of your main characters?
>> Sandhya Menon: Honestly,
personal experience.
I feel like when we-- when
my parents and I migrated
to the U.S., I could see that
my mother was struggling a whole
lot with the move.
And, she was extremely isolated.
She was actually a
very social person.
But, when we moved to the U.S.,
she had no friends at all.
We had lost a lot of our
wealth and resources,
and so she didn't really have,
you know, a way to get around,
and make those connections
any more.
People didn't understand
her when she spoke,
even though she spoke
English, really,
you know, perfect English.
But, it was heavily accented,
so people don't understand her,
and this was in the '90s, so
there was a lot less acceptance,
and so, she spent a lot of
her time alone, at home.
And, it was a really hard thing
to watch, because as a teenager,
I wanted to go out
and do things,
and explore my new
world, and my new culture.
And, she was just completely
shut down, and shut in.
And, I wanted to explore that,
because I feel like we don't see
that a whole lot when we
talk about immigration, and,
you know, moving completely away
from everything that you know,
especially as an adult,
how difficult that can be.
And so, I wanted to portray
her mom in a real way,
but also hopefully
in a sympathetic way.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
I really appreciated that her
mom is not magically fixed
by the end of the book.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: I mean,
she and Twinkle have found a
deeper connection, I think,
and Twinkle understands her
mom, but there's not this moment
where it's poof, now you're
not depressed anymore.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Which
is very true to life.
>> Sandhya Menon:
Right, exactly.
It's not-- there's no easy fix.
One of her big things
that she struggles with is
that her mom dies back home, and
Twinkle's mom is not able to go
to her mother's funeral.
And, that is a reality
that a lot
of immigrants face,
unfortunately.
And so, that can be
really, really, you know,
hard-hitting and heavy.
And, how do you ever get
over something like that?
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
Just takes time.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Since we're
talking about hard topics,
and you sort of referenced
this talking
about your mother's
experience of not having money,
but you write about class pretty
frankly in both of these books.
I love the scene where
Twinkle is with Dadi,
and they're carrying--
she's carrying this bowl
of water for her, right?
And, she says it's the
first time she's ever glad
that they live in
such a small house.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: You know,
or she's visiting her
love interest, right,
and they have this
really nice house,
and they've got a special glass
carafe for their orange juice.
And, she's like, we don't--
we use a carton, right?
>> Sandhya Menon: That's right.
What's wrong with a carton?
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
Yes. Why did you include
class in your novels?
>> Sandhya Menon: Like I
said, when we moved here,
I lost a lot of-- we
lost a lot of our wealth.
My dad was a highly educated
engineer, but when we moved
to the U.S. it didn't matter.
We lived in free
housing, you know,
where somebody was stabbed
on my street for $11.
There were sex workers
on our street.
Stuff was stolen out of my house
while I was sleeping in it.
So, we were really, really poor.
And, I remember that I went
to a little magnet
school, a high school.
And, a lot of the kids there
were, you know, kids of lawyers,
and doctors, and engineers
who had been here for a while.
And, it was so different
seeing that kind of lifestyle,
when I was, you know-- my car
broke down, my secondhand,
you know, car that my
dad bought for, like,
$200 bucks broke down.
And so, he had to get his
work to lend him a car
so he could come pick me up.
And then, meanwhile these kids
in their Beemers, you know,
driving by, like,
oh, what's she doing?
Is that vintage?
What does that car
look like that for?
And, I remember feeling so
isolated because of that.
And, of course, I had
friends who were also
in similar situations, like me.
But, it doesn't matter
when you're a teenager,
you feel so different.
All you notice is these
people have so much,
and it's so easy for them.
And, why isn't it
like that for me?
And, I wanted to put poverty
in a rom-com, because I feel
like it doesn't happen enough.
And, you know, just
like ethnicity.
Ethnic minorities don't
have to have a book about
"the struggle" all the time.
Poverty doesn't have
to be in books about
"the struggle," either.
So.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Right.
It could just be a fact
of a character's life.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
Right. Exactly.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Everyone always wants
to know about process, right?
You've written two
super-well-received novel,
while you have a whole
profession on the side.
Do you set yourself
word count goals?
Do you go into a novel knowing
how long it's going to be?
>> Sandhya Menon:
So, I have it easy
because after I sold a couple
of contracts, I have, you know,
I'm pretty much a
full-time writer.
I work part-time as a therapist.
So, I have a lot more time than
people who work during the day
in another profession, but I
still do set word count goals.
And, usually when I'm drafting,
that's 2,000 words a
day, five days a week.
And, that will get you
to 10,000 words per week,
which is pretty quick.
You can finish a novel in
about 8 weeks that way.
That doesn't count
editing for course,
which is a whole
nother ballgame.
So, not my favorite part.
But, yes, I have to treat
it like a job where I sit
down at my desk every-- you
know, when my kids leave
for school, that's my,
kind of, start time.
And then, I don't
get up from there
until I'm done with my goal.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Wow.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: What
do you read while you're
yourself writing?
>> Sandhya Menon: Lots
of different things.
I tend not to read YA
while I'm writing YA.
Because then it, like,
seeps into my writing.
I'm like, did I just
plagiarize that whole page?
So. That's bad.
So. I tend to read a
lot of non-fiction,
or adult fiction to, kind
of, balance things out.
>> Phoebe Connelly: And, is
there a prompt or a thing
that you do, when you've
got writer's block?
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
So, for me writer's block is
about not knowing
where to go next.
So, I realize then that I need
to plot a little more closely,
and so I'll get up and
actually go somewhere else
and plot what I need to do
next, and just brainstorm.
Because when I'm
sitting at the desk,
I feel like I'm staring
at my computer.
Nothing's coming.
So, I need a change of pace.
Or, if that doesn't work,
I'll just get up and, like,
go for a walk or a
hike or something.
Because I live in Colorado, so
there's lots of outdoorsy stuff,
so you can just walk out
your door, and, kind of,
get lost in the woods,
and you know,
it helps shake things free.
> Phoebe Connelly: Let's
talk about rom-coms
which you already,
sort of, mentioned.
We're having a rom-com
moment right now.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
And, I am so excited about that.
Finally our time has come!
[laughs]
>> Phoebe Connelly:
And, it also feels
like we're having this moment
of these refreshingly
non-problematic rom-coms, right?
Where you can, like,
just lose yourself.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
You're like, wow, that
was remarkably sexist.
You just slipped that
in there, did you.
I know, and I love it.
And, we were talking
earlier about this.
You know the rom-com
with Taye Diggs,
where the assistant
sets them up?
>> [inaudible]
>> Sandhya Menon: Set It Up.
I love that one.
I was so, like, I just
could watch it 1,000 times.
I love To All The
Boys I Loved Before.
I mean-- yes.
Right? I love that it's
become this phenomenon.
It's just amazing to me.
I'm so excited.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
I think having more diverse
rom-coms made them better.
>> Sandhya Menon: Exactly.
Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly: You
just teased your next novel,
which is a sequel to
When Dimple Met Rishi.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
So, which was harder?
Writing your second novel
or writing a sequel?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, God.
The second novel
There's, like, no contest.
Like, deleting 80,000 words,
I will always carry
those scars with me.
[laughs]
>> Phoebe Connelly: [laughs]
>> Sandhya Menon: You know,
actually, both the Dimple novel,
and the companion
coming out next summer,
they were both remarkably
easy, and, like,
who am I to fight that?
You know? I'm just
going to go with it.
So. Yes. No.
These were my easy novels.
Twinkle was the one
that really hurt.
[laughs]
>> Phoebe Connelly:
[laughs] Sounds good.
Well, do you all want
to start lining up,
and let's get some
questions from the audience?
>> Sandhya Menon:
That would be great!
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes.
And, I'll say, forgive us,
because we're a little
bit blinded by the lights.
We see you as sort of a shape.
If we look puzzled, that's why.
>> Sandhya Menon: [laughs]
>> Morning.
Hello?
>> Phoebe Connelly: Yes, hi!
>> Good morning, my name's
Marissa [assumed spelling].
First of all I just want
to clear my conscience
if that's OK, and check that
you still have those 80,000
words somewhere.
>> Sandhya Menon: [laughs]
They have been saved
in the Reject folder.
>> Very good.
So, my question is, what
are some of the challenges
that you face in
trying to normalize
or empower young adults
reading your novels?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh.
Some of the challenges
that I face--
that's such a great question.
I'm like, where do I begin?
I think that still
people think that--
they're struggling
to put me in a box.
They're, is it rom-com,
or its it multi-cultural?
Where should we put you?
And, more often than not,
they tend to go towards
multi-cultural.
And, I don't tend to like that
box, because this is a story
about American kids who
happen to be Indian American.
But, they are American kids,
and if they were white,
you would probably
not think twice
about saying it's
a romantic comedy.
And so, this is why I've
come to the conclusion
that I'm not going to
do panels, or interviews
where the only focus
is diversity,
and how are you changing the
landscape by writing these kids
who are not mainstream,
because this is mainstream now.
And so, that's, kind of, my
challenge still, I think,
is showing that this
is mainstream now.
But, that's why I love
the romantic comedies
that we were talking
about earlier.
Because that's all
normalizing it.
So, yes.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Hi, Ms. Menon.
>> Sandhya Menon: Hi!
>> I was wondering, you've
been writing rom-coms,
you've been saying that
you watch rom-coms,
what's your main, like, favorite
part of the rom-com genre?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh!
What's my favorite part?
Can I say, all the kissing?
Is that too trite?
No, I'm going to say
something deeper.
Wait, this is being recorded.
[laughs] No, all the kissing.
That's all I got.
>> Thank you, ma'am.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Hi.
>> Sandhya Menon: Hi.
>> My name's Olivia [assumed
spelling], and I just wanted
to ask, like, I read your
books, and all, like,
the characters are very
unique from each other.
So, like, how do you go
about writing each character
with their own unique
voice and personality?
And, do you draw any influences
from your real life from that?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh,
what a great question.
And, thank you for saying that.
I like to imagine my characters
kind of like a mini-movie
in my head before I write.
So, I'll just think--
I daydream a lot.
And, my husband will be
like, that's not working.
And, I'm like, yes it is.
Prove otherwise.
But, I think that daydreaming
is so important for writers.
Because you have to, just sit,
and, kind of, let it marinate.
You can't just start typing.
At least for me,
it doesn't work.
So, every time I think of
a character, I will write
down the character's
name, and, like,
some basic details about them.
And then, I'll spend
up to half a day,
even for secondary
characters, just daydreaming
about the things they like,
what they might do
in a funny situation.
You know. What they do
when things are hard?
What do they do when
things are easy?
That kind of thing.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> What is your favorite
part to write?
>> Sandhya Menon: My
favorite part to write.
I love writing endings.
Endings are really fun for me.
And, I hate writing beginnings.
Like, beginnings,
just getting started?
I don't know if it's the
tyranny of the blank page,
or I feel like it has to be the
best novel in the world, or,
you know, it's not worth it.
I don't know.
But, beginnings always stump
me, and endings are so great.
I love writing endings.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
I can't believe
that there's not a longer line.
I know you all have questions.
Yes. They're getting up, OK.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yay.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Well, while
they get to the microphone,
do you ever let yourself
write the ending first?
Or, do you make yourself wait?
>> Sandhya Menon: No.
I absolutely make myself
wait, because I feel like,
if you wait enough, things
that you didn't realize before,
you can tie together in a much
more satisfying way in the end,
that you didn't know, oh this
was a theme through the thing.
So-- and plus, it's kind of
like saving your dessert.
If you eat your dessert first,
don't want to eat your dinner?
So. If I just turned
in an ending,
I don't think my publisher
would like that too much.
>> Hello. Good morning.
>> Sandhya Menon: Hi.
>> You've mentioned before,
certainly, that, you know,
that you have a husband,
and you have kids,
and I'm not sure
necessarily how old they are,
but I'm curious how
you incorporate them
into your process, or, sort of,
talking about what you're doing
with your family, and how
they help you in terms
of producing the novels
that you've also come
out with thus far.
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, yes.
So, my husband is-- he's
got, I think I mentioned,
he's a very tech guy, and
so he's got a very logical,
kind of brain, which is not so
great with the creative stuff.
But, it's great if you have,
like, plot structure problems,
or other mechanical issues.
He's great at saying this is
why this part's not working.
And so, I use him
a lot for plot.
And then, my kids are 9 and
10, so they're a little young.
But, my daughter actually cried
when she saw the Dimple cover,
because she was like,
somebody who looks like us!
And, she was so excited.
And, she keeps asking me, like,
every six months,
can I read it yet?
Can I read it yet?
Not yet! You're only 9.
So, yes. She's like my
encouragement to keep writing.
>> Morning.
That actually inspires me
to ask a different question
than I was planning.
>> Sandhya Menon: Ask both!
>> Well, your covers for
your books are amazing.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Covers are so important,
and yours are beautiful,
and so perfectly rom-com-y.
Can you talk a little bit about
the process you went through?
How much input you had on
the way the covers looked?
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
So, I am very lucky in that
my publisher consults me
on the cover.
And, they actually send
me model portfolios
so I can pick the exact model.
And, on the books, like
there's the front cover,
and the back cover has,
like, the male model too.
Which I love, so I get
to pick two models.
And, get to look at
pretty pictures of models.
[laughs] But, anyway, so yes,
I actually get a
decent amount of say.
They don't ask me
from, you know--
and I wouldn't want
to be in there
from the beginning to the end.
But, they say this is, kind of,
the direction we're thinking.
What do you think?
And, I'll say yes or no.
And then, you know, I'll
request little tweaks and stuff,
and they usually do them.
So, I'm really lucky in that,
yes, I get to do, I think,
I lot more than authors
typically get to do.
>> Can I ask-- this is sort
of the inevitable question,
but other than the
companion novel to Dimple,
what are you working on next?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, you said
other than the companion novel?
Oh, yes. So, I have
a series in the works
that I haven't announced yet,
even though I sold it, like,
a year and a half ago.
So--
>> Phoebe Connelly: We're
breaking news on the stage!
>> Sandhya Menon: I know!
>> Phoebe Connelly: A series.
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, wait, I
forgot this is being recorded.
[laughs] So, it is
a whole new trilogy,
and it's set in a
boarding school.
And, it's a boarding
school for elites, like,
there are some royals and some
British aristocrat-type people.
And, they're based
loosely on fairy tales.
So, while there's
no magic, per se,
they are contemporary novels,
there is, like, a is it a curse
or isn't it a curse
kind of thing.
And, the first one is based
on Beauty and the Beast.
[laughs] Thanks for asking that.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
I'm excited now.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yay.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait.
I can't wait until I can
actually publicly talk about it.
[laughs] I'm dying.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Have you
already written the first one?
>> Sandhya Menon: I have!
Yes. And, I just finished the
first round of edits on it.
So. I know!
I'm dying.
>> Phoebe Connelly: We've
got a few more minutes,
are there any other
questions from the audience?
You all are being so polite,
and saving your questions.
I know you're burning up.
>> Sandhya Menon: Right.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Ah, yes.
Please.
>> Sandhya Menon:
There's two of them.
>> When Dimple Met Rishi,
I'm assuming was inspired
by the Nora Ephron
movie, with the title?
You know, because it's
like when Harry Met Sally,
and I was wondering if
the title came first,
or how did you choose
[inaudible].
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, so it
was actually originally Dimple
and Rishi, very simple,
like Eleanor and Park?
And then, my editor had
this idea, she was like,
what about for the Dimple
universe novels, if we take,
like, a classic rom-com,
and change it up?
And so, When Dimple Met Rishi,
and then the next one is
There's Something About Sweetie.
Like, There's Something
About Mary.
So. I just loved that idea.
I was like, yes.
Because it's like
rom-coms have rebooted,
like we were talking about.
Yes.
>> Do all of your books
have happy endings, or no?
>> Sandhya Menon: Did
you say happy endings?
>> Yes.
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh, yes.
If they didn't, I would never
be able to forgive myself.
[laughs] Yes.
All of them do.
>> OK.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
That's so sweet.
>> Hi. I wanted to ask how
you go about, like, planning
or outlining your novels.
Like, what is your
process for that?
>> Sandhya Menon: Oh.
If you're on Instagram,
you can follow me there.
I post a lot about my process.
I post pictures, and
videos, and stuff.
So, I plot out, and I use little
sticky notes to do my whole arc.
And, if you haven't looked into
the Plot Whisperer workbook,
I highly recommend that.
It's by Martha Alderson.
And, it's an amazing way to
begin plotting your novel.
>> Thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
>> Hi. So, I feel like we've
been talking about rom-coms
so much, so I feel like I have
to ask, are there any movies
in the works for
either of your books?
>> Sandhya Menon: Movies?
Oh! So, unfortunately, like,
you have to have, like,
a super duper super clearance to
talk about that kind of stuff.
So, there has been interest
in the Dimple books,
but it's like super early days,
and a lot of times things never
happen past the early days.
So, that's all I have to
share right now, sadly.
>> Phoebe Connelly: Ooh.
Something to keep us waiting.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
Fingers crossed.
>> [inaudible]
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes, exactly.
>> Phoebe Connelly: We
should all keep asking
for the movie adaptation.
>> Sandhya Menon: Exactly.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Right, well, so, Sandhya,
thank you so much
for joining us today.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank you.
>> Phoebe Connelly: And, I hope
everyone gets a chance to check
out her books, if
you haven't already.
And, we will wait
in anticipation,
not only for the
next Dimple book,
but also for your new series.
>> Sandhya Menon: Thank
you so much, Phoebe.
>> Phoebe Connelly:
Alright, thank you.
>> Sandhya Menon: Yes.
Thanks, guys.